[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
olivier faur le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous de nous extraire
évidemment de la fête des bleus pour
répondre à nos questions d'ailleurs en
lien avec cette magnifique victoire qui
place la france au dessus du monde comme
on dit depuis hier soir n'est ce pas
olivier faur d'abord comment est ce que
vous avez vécu cette finale ou avec qui
j'étais avec les jeunes nous aligner le
temple on était dans une grande salle
avec un grand écran et je les ai vus
exulter comme jamais ouais même à tel
point que j'ai vu que l'écran elle est
tombée à chaque but mais il était voilà
il était à fond comme on dit d'accord
porté par ce bonheur que l'on dit
éternelle 1
je l'espère en tout cas qui va durer
quelques semaines et c'est vrai moi une
formidable victoire une fois diable
parcours d'abord de cette équipe
et donc c'était un moment où à nouveau
la france se racontait une histoire
qu'elle faisait avec elle réalisé
ensemble et puis c'est un moment aussi
où on avait retrouvé le goût de la fête
ensemble c'est pas si fréquent dans un
pays qui a été meurtri et meurtri
verrière de la beaucoup pleuré le voir à
nouveau chanter la marseillaise pour de
bonnes raisons et pas simplement parce
qu'on est en deuil
c'était formidable alors avec moi donc
pour vous interroger ce soir oriane
mancini et stéphanie le rouge bonsoir
mesdames
merci d'être là pour ce nouveau
rendez-vous de l'épreuve de vérité
réalisé en partenariat avec les échos
radio classique l agence france presse
trois grandes questions pour vous ce
soir injustement le climat d'union
nationale oblige-t-il tous les
politiques comment le prolonger en tirer
avantage 2 derrière le rêve la réalité
qui est toujours la même comment
répondre aux attentes des français
puisque les problèmes ne se sont pas
volatilisé enfin troisième question à
quand un ps à l'image des bleus 1
c'est-à-dire rassemblé une itt est
involontaire et ayant appris de ses
erreurs et la première question vous est
posée par oriane mancini
[Musique]
olivier faur on a vu hier soir ces
milliers ces centaines de milliers de
français descendre dans la rue est ce
que ce climat d'union nationale qui
règne depuis hier oblige tous les
politiques et surtout comment faire pour
le prolonger mais j'aimerais bien qu'on
ne mélange pas tout je sais bien que le
moment est tentant y compris pour les
uns et pour les autres de chercher à
associer leur image à celle d'une équipe
qui vient de gagner mais c'est une
équipe qui a gagné sportivement et qui
ne doit pas maintenant conditionner le
débat politique qu'est l'essence cela
aurait de dire que parce que l'équipe de
france a gagné la coupe du monde il faut
que majorité et opposition et s'unissent
à l'assemblée j'aimerais pouvoir le
faire à vous dites vous dites là pas
question un mélo ouais c'est pas et sait
pas que c'est nos essais que en réalité
on nous a promis un nouveau monde il y a
un an mais où est il ce nouveau monde
moi je ne vois en fait qu'une vieille
politique avec des arguments avec une
façon de de faire vivre le débat
politique et puis même des propositions
qui datent beaucoup en réalité ce qui
nous est déroulé chaque jour c'est une
politique qui est une politique on
qualifie habituellement de néo libéral
je ne vois aucune raison de la soutenir
même si les bleus ont gagné souvent je
me félicite que vous dites longtemps
pour certains c'est à dire que manuel
mac on cherche à faire de la
récupération politique
il nous a dit qu'il ne le ferait pas
donc je veux croire que il se tiendra sa
promesse et son engagement et que bien
sûr il se tiendra à l'écart de toute
tentative de récupération d'un événement
qui est né hors de nuire de nous et qui
est d'abord lié au talent d'une équipe
et que vous voyez vous estimez que je
sais pas et il a choisi la voie du juste
milieu
je ne sais pas si juste mieux cela c'est
votre jugement bon écoutez moi je pense
que c'est de bonne guerre que tous les
présidents de la république ont cherché
à leurs heures à s'approprier une
victoire qui n'était pas de leur fait
il n'est pas le premier et ne sera pas
le dernier et donc je le vois il ne
s'appelle à 20 personnes qu'il a envie
de marquer de son image cette victoire
et comment lever reprocher puisque c'est
à peu près ce que tous ont fait mais
personne n'est dupe ni les français
d'hier ni ceux d'aujourd'hui et ceux de
demain
voilà mais lui c'est un vrai amateur et
connaisseur de foot contrairement au
président qui était là il ya vingt ans
pour la première étoile jacques chirac
je sais pas je crois que jacques chirac
aimait le football aussi françois
hollande là mais aussi mignonne macron
l'aiment aussi très bien mais ça ne fait
pas d'eux pour autant les auteurs d'une
victoire donc c'est chacun à sa place
est à vous gênerait un qu'ils en tirent
avantage par exemple non mais je sais
que dans les sondages il en tirera
avantage simplement ce que je dis c'est
que là où on aimerait qu'il soit
champion du monde c'est comme dans la
vie de tous les inégalités ça serait pas
mal dans la lutte contre la pauvreté ce
serait pas mal plutôt que d'avoir un
président qui repousse vendre reuth et à
plus tard pour cause de finale oppose
deux demi finales voilà on aimerait la
voir comme champion et la scène et je
vais dire autre chose en fait je n'aime
pas beaucoup dans la vie politique en
général c'est pas spécifiques emmanuel
macron ces gens qu'ils s'approprient le
travail des autres et c'est vrai que ce
président en matière de croissance 3
août la footballistique de lutte contre
le chômage et cetera a pris pour
habitude s'approprier le travail de ceux
qui l'ont précédé ou de ceux qui sont en
train de les gars c est donc ce serait
bien que chacun reste à sa place et que
chacun s'associe à cette victoire et que
nous accompagnons le mieux que nous
puissions cette très belle victoire
cette très belle équipe mais justement
d'un tirant toutes les leçons et la
leçon de cette équipe sait que c'est une
équipe on n'a pas simplement jouer le
premier de cordée on a joué toute la
corde et vous avez vu que match après
match on a eu du queen's arrières qui
sont venus marquer d avant centre qui
sont venus défendre et bien ça c'est
l'idée de l'équipe que je me fais c'est
à dire en fait une équipe solidaire et
non pas simplement une équipe qui compte
sur ses ténors voilà c'est fait des
leçon politique à tirer de cette
victoire il ya beaucoup de ces joueurs
qui sont issus des quartiers comme on
dit est ce que justement il faut
peut-être mettre le paquet sur ses
banlieues qui réussissent quand les
aides
ce qui est dommage c'est que on ne nous
parle de cette france bleu blanc rouge
que les jours des victoires
j'aimerais bien qu'on en parle toute
l'année je suis même cet anneau quartier
danton dit on parle souvent et je sois
même issue pour moitié de l'immigration
et donc ce n'est pas
un sujet qui mettront à table tous les
jours parce que je considère que je suis
français à part entière à 100% comme qui
a même qui aiment la paix comme pokba
comme tous ceux qui ont fait notre joie
hier soir et ce qui distingue peut-être
cette france d'hier soir par pastel 10 à
20 ans et qu'on ne se sent plus obligé
de dire que c'est une france black blanc
beur c'est une france qui est faite de
gens qui ont des origines diverses et
qui sont tout simplement français est ce
qui distingue un zizou de me taper c'est
que en fait on avait il ya vingt ans des
joueurs qui étaient en fête avec des
parents qui étaient arrivés dans une
vague migratoire
aujourd'hui vous avez des enfants qui
sont nés en france pas tous y en a deux
qui sont effectivement né hors de nos
frontières
mais en dehors de ces deux là tous les
autres sont nés en france de parents
français et donc ils sont 100 % français
cette distinction n'a plus de sens
hier à savigny-le-temple dans ma ville
en fait il y avait des enfants de toutes
origines et c'était une évidence pour
eux que le drapeau qui était voleurs
s'étaient le drapeau français n'y avait
même pas d'hésitation une seule passe
rien voilà c'était certain marseillaise
comme n'importe quel est le plan
banlieue sur le plan borloo qui
justement n'aura pas lieu est ce que ce
que c'est une erreur
regarde ce que je vais en partie répondu
que vous ai dit qu'on ne parlait de
cette france là que vos deux matches à
dire que en fait on est très heureux de
trouver des jeunes qui finalement vaine
nous remplir de fierté mais on les
oublie le reste du temps et on les
oublie même à matha sportive parce que
ce qui est terrible dans cette histoire
c'est que bon pour la pour la
compétition internationale
on met les moyens mais que se passe-t-il
depuis un an on a un président qui nous
dit qu'ils adorent le foot mais qui a
baissé
l'aide au football et qui a fait 10 mai
magna drastique les emplois aidés qui
servait précisément au club se porte
donc vous des vous estimant qu'il faut
prendre des décisions concrètes des
colons il y a un double langage qui ne
peut pas durer c'est dire que soit on
souhaite avoir des jeunes qui par le
sport se socialise qui par le sport se
dépassent qui par le sport apprennent
l'esprit d'équipé après la citoyenneté
apprennent la france mais et danser car
il faut mettre les moyens
alors vous dites vous reprochez emmanuel
macron de s'approprier la victoire des
autres mais j'ai l'impression que tous
les français ça
repris le discours que tiennent les
joueurs et didier deschamps également je
pense à taper sur leur amour de la
patrie sur tous pour la france
on va écouter par exemple à turin didier
deschamps le soir la victoire hier des
bleus et comme le dit notre président de
la république vive la république
alors ça quand même c'est à ces idées
dit non est-ce que vous adhérez
évidemment est ce que là vous dise
effectivement il y à un signal important
qui est envoyé par ses joueurs à toute
la jeunesse de france
oui parce que ils disent qu'ils sont non
seulement français mais aussi
républicain et qu'ils adhèrent à des
valeurs qui sont celles de la république
et c'est un message extrêmement puissant
c'est à dire qu'à un moment où on
pouvait il ya deux trois ans avoir des
débats sur cette france des quartiers
qui serait peut-être en marche que
c'était être finalement à distance de ce
qu'est l'idéal républicain qui serait en
marge
et bien il ya soir cette france là elle
a montré qu'elle était à l'unisson de
l'ensemble du pays et que elle était
complètement là il y avait des enfants
de langres une fois dans le quartier de
toutes les origines des femmes voilées
ou pas qui était là et qu'ils chantaient
la marseillaise et qui était heureuse de
vivre avec nous ce moment parce que
c'était leur pays et la république donc
ça nous rappelle cette victoire que la
france reste un creuset républicain
égalitaire c'est une promesse qui
méritent d'être approfondis parce que
malheureusement l'égalité elle reste
souvent à la porte du vestiaire et elle
n'est pas partagée par l'ensemble dès
territoires où il ya une vraie
difficulté entre rite vous avez enfin
tout le monde l'a compris
on dit toujours que la politique de la
ville ça coûte un peu dingue mais la
vérité c'est que on met aujourd'hui
moins d'argent dans ces quartiers là que
dans les quartiers chics et donc
vraiment vraiment mais vraiment il ya
des études qui ont été réalisées
récemment et qui font la démonstration
que l'argent qui me chaque année dans
les quartiers les plus favorisés et bien
est infiniment supérieur à ce qu'on met
pour la politique de la ville c'est une
évidence parce que pour la politique de
la ville on cherche à ramener ces
quartiers-là à un niveau de 5 septembre
mais est allé ce qui se passe dans tous
les domaines dans le domaine
nono culturelle dans le domaine de la
propreté dans le domaine des voix dans
le domaine de l'école dans le domaine de
la sécurité
regardez ce qui se fait dans paris
regardez ce qui s'est fait dans ma
commune c'est sans comparaison possible
et donc je ne dis pas que il faillait
allait forcément stigmatiser les villes
riches mais je dis simplement qu'il ya
un problème d'égalité dans ce pays qui
n'est pas un héros vous dites mais
qu'ils méritent d'être corrigés il que
l'égalité reste à la porte des
vestiaires elle reste aussi à la porte
des écoles
est-ce que l'école aujourd'hui joue
encore son rôle d'ascenseur social a
suffisamment bien sûr et insuffisamment
c'est encore un ascenseur qui restent
bloqués au premier étage pour la plupart
parce que on ne corrige pas les
inégalités de naissance avec une école
qui est jeu prenant là aussi des
exemples la propre circonscription
vous avez des enfants qui sont à quatre
dans une même chambre et comment vous
pensez que ces enfants là ont la même
capacité à se scolariser a avancé canto
les parents ne parlent pas forcément la
langue française que même sont en grande
difficulté que ne sont pas accompagnés
donc là effectivement si on est pas le
cas dans ces quartiers là et pour
s'excuser je parlais des emplois aidés
comment est ce qu'on fait pour les
accompagner il faut qu'ils aient des
structures il faut qu'ils aient des gens
qu'ils soient là pour compenser cette
inégalité de naissance et faire en sorte
qu' il puisse avancer et quand ils le
peuvent les avances alors on ne va pas
passer sous silence des incidents qui se
sont produits à paris mais aussi dans
plusieurs grandes villes de france à
lyon à marseille hier soir un
l'irruption de casseurs et de pilleurs
avec à peu près 300 gardes à vue sur
tout le territoire national est ce que
c'est un phénomène alarmant selon vous
jeudi alors qu'il était marginal par
rapport au nombre de françaises et de
français qui dans les rues hier soir
j'ai fait le déplacement entre savigny
le temple et paris pour aller sur les
champs elysées avec mes enfants
oui eh bien je j'ai vu partout en fait
c'était tout le long du trajet il y
avait des drapeaux des gens qui
chantaient qui hurlait qui manifestaient
leur joie quand on me dit qu'un à
quelques centaines qui sont venus casser
je me dis que c'était quand même très
marginale par rapport à l'ensemble et
que la plupart sont venus dans un état
d'esprit qui était le meilleur fêter une
victoire ensemble alors vous dites que
je veux et tu as donc s'approprie la
victoire des bleus mais ça je dis que
vous l'avez déjà fait avant je veux dit
aussi mais je dis que je n'en fais pas
je dis que tout ce qu'on fait avant lui
que des blogueurs après lui sa colère
mais mais je vais vous montrer quelques
images pour vous montrer que les bleus
bas ils ont partagé leur victoire avec
un actionnaire et le tard c'était dans
les vestiaires regarder ça vous a plu
le voir comme ça le chef de l'état que
vous combattez jour après jour mais je
le crois pas parce qu'il fait sur les
noirs août
je tiens je combat sur le terrain
politique et donc ça ne va très bien
qu'elle va vous avez problème à l'effort
la deuxième question de l'épreuve de
vérité on va revenir à la politique
c'est stéphanie le rouge qui va vous
poser cette question dans un assaut
[Musique]
stéphanie d'un puisque derrière le rêve
il ya toujours la réalité la réalité le
clan pauvreté la loi logement et c'est
donc dans
on voulait savoir comment vous
souhaité que le chef de l'état oriente
sa politique dans les prochains mois
est-ce qu'il doit retrouver sa jambe
gauche qu'il a pu donner l'impression
d'avoir perdu
je ne sais pas s'il doit la retrouver
parce que je ne sais pas si l une
il ya eu une jambe gauche un jour et les
écarts de gauche pour emmanuel macron
c'est vrai et même pour le deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle nombreux
pour voter contre le front national en
revanche est ce qu'il ya derrière une
jambe gauche à vie à la politique de
venelles macron je ne suis pas stressé
je n'en suis pas sûr et pour tout dire
ça fait longtemps que je pense que s'il
existe une jambe gauche c'est une jambe
de bois
mais je ne l'espérais pas non plus il a
fait un discours très clair à la sai
lundi dernier il a été extrêmement
limpide dans l'esprit qui l'animent
c'est un libéral il n'ya rien attendre
de cette politique là pour ceux qui
cherchent qui espère un deuxième temps
de gauche il a dit les choses
il a dix mois les inégalités spot mais
c'est pas mon problème je me bats
uniquement contre les inégalités de
destin donc quand j'ai fait mon boulot
sur l'école et la formation c'est fini
après c'est le marché qui vous juge et
vous êtes inégaux c'est normal c'est pas
un souci pour moi après dit il faut
qu'ils aient un gâteau pour qu'on puisse
le partager mais il ya bien un gâteau
qu'il entend réaliser avec le pays mais
il a simplement enlevé le couteau pour
pouvoir partager il faut un couteau
derrière pour pouvoir répartir à parts
égales où est ma part inégale sauf que
il détruit tous les outils du partage du
gâteau la politique fiscale et sur les
services publics et donc il n'y aura pas
de deuxième jambe parce que il a remis
entièrement le sort de la france dans
les mains du marché le rôle de l'état
pour emmanuel macron c'est un état qui
fluidifie l'accès au marché
lors de ce discours au congrès justement
il s'est retourné néanmoins vers les
corps intermédiaires vers les syndicats
et donc demain un sommet social qui
s'est réunie est ce que là il n'ya pas
quand même une inflexion un retour vers
vers les corps intermédiaires
j'aimerais tellement le croire
j'aimerais tellement élevé à la réunion
c'est un signe c'est la fin des réunions
quand même un sommet à l'elysée des
syndicats y vont ils l'attendaient ce
moment eux
oui moi aussi je l'attendais alors il a
lieu il a lieu on verra ce qu'il donne
parce que pour l'instant vous aurez
remarqué que que fait-il à chaque fois
il agite en fait là le chiffon rouge
sous le nez des uns et les autres ils
cherchent à provoquer une forme de
radicalité et ensuite ils se posent en
espèces de parangon de la modération
c'est ce qu'il a fait sur la question de
la sncf
pourquoi n'at-il pas commencer par le
commencement pourquoi n'at-il pas
commencer par parler de la dette
pourquoi comment sais tu pas qu'on sait
pas négocier avec ceux qui veulent
négocier
pourquoi at-il agiter le chiffon rouge
du statut de la sncf et a su des
cheminots alors même que ces questions
là n'était absolument pas prioritaire
dans le débat sur l'avenir du service
public ferroviaire
tout simplement parce que il a choisi de
gagner une victoire contre les plus
radicaux et qu'il a cherché à la
construire la mettre en scène
et donc c'est tout ce qu'il fait de
piano et vous aurez remarqué que étape
après étape
il prend un malin plaisir à éradiquer
tous les corps intermédiaires ça a été
vrai pour les élus locaux c'est vrai
c'était vrai pour les syndicats c'est
vrai maintenant pour alors allez vous
travailler là encore coup de com alors
peut-être demain le sommet de l'elysée
il a compris que quelque chose se
passait et qu'ils avaient besoin donné
des signaux mais vous voyez bien que à
chaque fois ils ont certes il ne négocie
jamais sur aucun sujet il ne l'a pas
fait il avoue dit que sa première fois
qu'il réunit non l'an passé à la même
époque
après sa victoire il avait rencontré
largement abondamment les syndicats il
avait même de énuméré le nombre d'heures
passées le monde syndical
quand on était à la veille des
ordonnances pénicaud si on ne travaille
pas d'inflexion mais pour l'instant
panne affleck chaleur alors je ne suffit
pas de réunir pour réussir il faut
encore pouvoir en faire la démonstration
de points ça n'est pas la carrière
c'était le
sujet de la première question de notre
sondage opinionway pour l'épreuve de
vérité
souhaitez vous que le gouvernement mène
une politique plus sociale c'est un oui
et l'acquis et domine à 53% plus
libérale 19 % identique et celle qui est
menée actuellement 26 % donc là vous
êtes en phase avec cette demande d'une
politique plus sociale et les seuls qui
sont en phase avec le public ses 19 %
parce que ce qu'il veut faire pour les
prochaines années
c'est une politique plus libérale mais
alors vous écouter on vous écoute on s'y
attendait mais on a trop vous avez
découvert un nouveau personnage dont
vous avez que depuis toujours vous
l'imaginiez comme ça vous aviez perçu le
personnage vous pensiez qu'il n'était
plus libérale encore que françois fillon
je ne pensais pas forcément au démarrage
de son mandat alors qu'il procéderait
ainsi pourquoi
non pas parce pour ce qu'il était
lui-même mais parce que il possédait
d'une d'un vote d'une majorité qui
n'était pas exactement une majorité qui
l'avaient soutenu moi-même au deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle j'ai
appelé à voter pour lui et j'ai voté
pour lui avouer je considère même chose
que mélenchon finalement vous l'estimez
mais non j'ai lu les gens schéma mené ça
peut n'être pas du tout jean luc
mélenchon n'a pas appelé à voter pour
emmanuel macron deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle moi je les
fais parce que je ne voulais pas que le
front national puisse progresser dans
cette élection
mais je pensais que contrairement à
jacques chirac qui en 2002 avait oublié
au lendemain de sa victoire qu'il avait
été élu par une majorité très large plus
de 80% des français à l'époque
j'imaginais que neil mac rond se
sentirait obligé par les gens qui
allaient voter pour lui il en est
malheureusement rien et je le regrette
jour après jour parce que je préférais
être conduit à dire que finalement ce
que fait ce gouvernement c'est pas si
mal
ça m'arrangerait pas honnête mais je
préférais peut-être en cherchant bien
vous êtes peut-être trouvé quelque chose
de positif mais j'ai parfois voter avec
cette majorité mais rarement je les fais
sur des questions qui ne sont pas
forcément prioritaire parce que sur le
terrain économique social sur la
politique migratoire sur l'appétit
sociétale je n'ai pas vu encore à ce
stade une politique qui a été menée très
différemment par alain juppé françois
fillon
justement vous parlez la loi pénicaud le
sénat a voté ce matin la réforme
pénicaud sur l'assurance-chômage la
formation professionnelle
l'apprentissage
elle se veut
le volet protection des réformes
d'emmanuel macron de son objectif est
d'accorder plus de droits aux salariés
est ce que c'est le cas pour vous vous
retournez la question est-ce que vous
avez vu dans cette dans ce texte la
trace d'une protection supplémentaire
pour les salariés
on nous avait dit voilà la flexibilité à
l'automne mais au printemps vous aurez
enfin la sécurité est ce que quelqu'un
pense que nous avons la sécurité même
cette grande promesse qui a été faite
pendant l'élection présidentielle te
dire que l'assurance chômage serait
étendu à ceux qui démissionnent à ceux
qui sont indépendants et ça est-ce que
vous avez vu que vous dire quelque chose
vous avez en fait je sais plus et un
pour cent de ceux qui vont démissionner
qui auront effectivement la possibilité
peut-être un peu plus maussade et
pensait alors le de leurs dossiers quand
même 1 de la constitution de leur
profession je me souviens avoir entendu
un candidat expliqué que tous les
d'abord c'était tout le monde qui a
présenté un droit de tirage qui était de
tous les hits années maintenant c'est en
fait c'est ricky qui ont façonné sur un
truc une minuscule pour quelques ces
deux mille personnes qui en
bénéficieront chaque année alors que je
crois qu'il ya deux cent mille démission
chaque année à gagner rien qui vous va
dans cette love sakho notamment le
compte personnel de formation pour que
face à de l'information il été créé par
nous donc en fait tout ça c'est pas une
création tune qui se transforme keith
accrédite en euros et plus en heures
espace assez négative non mais ça c'est
une régression typiquement imaginez que
vous aviez hier vous étiez un salarié
prend un exemple un peu caricatural mais
pour me faire comprendre vous étiez au
marteau piqueur nom vous dit vous avez
40 heures qui vous sont donnés pour vous
former et vous vous dites très bien
j'essaie de prendre ses 40 heures pour
pouvoir changer de métier et faire un
métier moins pénible c'est m y compris
la logique du conte pénibilité qui a été
raboté à voter raboté eh bien vous aviez
des heures maintenant vous dit c'est de
l'argent et ça change tout ça veut dire
que en fait le problème c'est que vous
allez avoir en fait un
un budget mais qui ne correspond pas
forcément à 40 heures mais peut-être
simplement à 20h et donc pour vous c'est
une régression par rapport à ce qu'ils
étaient l'an passé votre votre dossier
votre compte donc je ne vois pas là
encore de raison de se réjouir
particulièrement
j'aurais aimé si on garde l'image du
sportif et du footballeur évidemment
vous dites là si emmanuel macron et
que le foot c'est comme la politique ça
se joue sur deux jambes c'est mieux ces
lieux il ya aussi le handisport qu'il
faut saluer mais enfin en l'occurrence
je préfère quand effectivement les gens
marchent sur des gens et et je préfère
quand le pied d'impulsion c'est le pied
gauche alors il ya parmi les grands
projets de réforme bien sûr les
économies budgétaires les efforts est-ce
que vous avez l'impression qu'on assiste
à un grand escamotage ou un grand
camouflage parce que on n'a pas
véritablement les chiffres et quand
gérald darmanin présente la réforme de
bercy on avait évoqué vingt mille
suppressions de postes il réussit
l'exploit de ne donner aucun chiffre
mais comme sur beaucoup de sujets vous
aurez remarqué que c'est le fou depuis
quelques semaines c'est le flou surtout
sur tous les sujets sur les suppressions
d'emplois sur ce qui va se passer dans
la fonction publique avec ce fameux
rapport cap 2022 qui a disparu des
écrans radar on ne sait pas ce qui se
passe sur les retraites pour les
pensions de réversion un jour on nous
dit blanc le lendemain on nous dit noir
bord ils ont toujours dit officiellement
du côté de l'exécutif que ce ne serait
pas mis en cause la présence du chef de
l'état elle chef de l'état me lisez le
co 10 min c'est parce qu'ils ont dit à
versailles le chef de l'état a dit pour
les prenons version actuelle actuelle
d'accord et la ministre madame busin
dans les jours qui ont suivi a expliqué
que c'était valable uniquement pour les
femmes qui n'avaient pas travaillé
pardon du flou en fait on vous plus
exactement on voit bien que ce n'est pas
tout à fait claires et qu' ils cherchent
à nous masquer ce qu'est l'intention
réelle et donc c'est pour ça que je vois
bien que au fur et à mesure sur tous ces
sujets là on est en train de nous deux
ne nous dit pas tout vous aviez une
expression sur le bout de la langue
on nous dit pas tout c'est cette
émission que enfin une comique mais ce
n'est pas si drôle certains comme
stéphane le foll craignent une impasse
budgétaire même c'est à dire que
la raison il explique c'est que
gouvernement a beaucoup dépensé au début
du quinquennat avec des cadeaux fiscaux
entre guillemets et que désormais la
croissance étant plus faible que ce qui
est attendu
l'heure des vaches maigres est arrivé
c'est aussi ce que vous craignez je ne
sais pas si c'est l'heure des vaches
maigres mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que on a beaucoup dépensé
au début de ce quinquennat à tord et à
travers et que aujourd'hui à des gens
qui doivent payer
on aurait pu faire d'autres choix nous
avions présenté dans le cadre de débats
parlementaires un contre budget dans
lequel nous montrions que nous pouvions
passer par un autre chemin et qu'on
pouvait notamment ne pas avoir cette
injustice crasse qui a été fait à tous
les retraités de france avec la csg qui
a augmenté y compris pour des gens qui
gagne 1200 euros par mois eh bien
c'était possible de faire différemment
malheureusement le choix qui a été fait
c'est d'aller mettre cet argent tu te du
côté des plus riches qui ne lui rendent
pas car vous l'aurez observé personne
n'investit davantage en france on a même
des fortunes qui s'exporte au luxembourg
ces jours ci et qui considèrent que
c'est la meilleure place pour faire des
affaires
donc on le voit bien tout ça est une est
une idée qui est aussi vieille que le
libéralisme cette idée du ruissellement
avec des riches qu'on arrose et des
pauvres qui finiront par avoir quelques
gouttes mais ça ne marche pas ça n'a
jamais marché nulle part sur la planète
et donc voilà on continue à faire crédit
je sais pas pourquoi c'est une c'est une
légende urbaine qui n'a pas de réalité
mais qu'on continue à véhiculer comme si
elle avait provoqué un jour quelque
chose quelque effet vous avez beaucoup
parlé du discours d' emmanuel macron au
congrès lors de ce discours il a annoncé
que désormais il souhaitait modifier la
constitution pour pouvoir écouter les
parlementaires et leur répondre est ce
que pour vous c'est le signe d'une
hyperprésidentialisation c'est le signe
d'un bricolage bricolage après le
décollage on en arrive à des trucs bafa
c'est sarkozy avait demandé à pouvoir
parler devant le congrès c'était déjà
une incongruité puisque comme vous savez
le président est élu par tous les
français mais qu'il n'est pas
responsable devant l'assemblée c'est
premier ministre qu'il est et donc c'est
le premier ministre qui normalement fait
le lien entre le pouvoir exécutif et
législatif
et lui il est celui qui engage y compris
sa responsabilité devant le parlement et
qui peut être sanctionné là vous avez un
président qui parle mais qui n'écoute
pas et qui ne répond pas il dit qu'à
cela ne tienne année prochaine je
reviens et je me dis pas cela il a
répondu à certaines critiques venues de
la gauche justement durba et je resterai
et je répondre la critique n'est pas
celle là qui dit que ce n'est pas de
changer la constitution
c'est de ne pas utiliser un moyen il à
s'exprimer il peut le faire il aurait
très bien pu 14 juillet comme chaque
année accepter que des analyses qu'il
pose des questions je soutiens toutes
les démocraties
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué qu'on
a un président qui n'aime pas les
questions et qui n'aime pas qu'on lui
réponde et qui n'aiment pas qu'on
interroge donc il m
en fait cette façon de procéder en
majesté et donc ils pérorent et puis
ensuite il s'en va donc on visait que
moi j'aurais préféré non pas qu'ils
viennent répondre devant l'assemblée je
préfère que chacun soit dans son rôle il
est ministre et joue ce rôle là mais
j'aurais préféré qu'il est effectivement
un débat qu analyste comme chaque année
14 juillet ensuite s'il veut modifier la
constitution
il en a la possibilité s'il veut un
régime qu'on appelle présidentielle
bercy veut aller plus loin et donc dire
désormais on a un régime présidentiel
j'assume premier ministre exit très bien
exit premier ministre et puis séparation
des pouvoirs c'était une demande
formulée par france ou en avant lui par
dominique strauss kahn vincent peillon
par d'autres socialistes qui ont émis
cette idée là il y en a d'autres qui
sont plutôt pour un régime primo
ministériel
moi je veux bien qu'on ait ce débat là
mais ça c'est un vrai débat pas un débat
où on improvise chaque seconde chaque
semaine en fonctionnaires du temps en
fonction des critiques et vous sont
faites et ses propositions successives
plombe ce projet selon vous cette
réforme
sachant qu'il aura peut-être pas là avec
la mobilisation de la droite au sénat
notamment la majorité des trois
cinquièmes mais moi j'espère que cette
réforme soit alors oui là les deux
hypothèses posées 1 soit ils acceptent
d'amendé très largement son projet et
dans ces cas là moi je suis prêt à la
voter soit soit effectivement c'est une
régression colossal je parle pas
simplement de la révision
constitutionnelle mais des trois lois
qui se suivent qui forme un bloc et qui
sont une dénaturation de notre
démocratie telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui accord mais vous espérez un
référendum
moi je souhaite que cette question là ne
puisse pas être éclipsé voyez bien que
l'on est en train de parler tout
simplement de la loi fondamentale de la
loi démocratique celle qui régit nos
institutions
on en parle en plein été à un moment où
tout
sur la coupe du monde de football est ce
que vous trouvez normal que les français
ne soient pas associés à un débat qui
devrait être un débat prioritaire pour
eux alors vous avez dit qu'il y avait un
surplace sur les sujets de société
également un volet avait mentionné est
là justement il ya député de la
république en marche
oriane qu'ils mobilisent pour un texte
ni à me progressent d'ailleurs du chef
de l'état guillaume fils qui déposent
une proposition de loi la semaine
prochaine pour ouvrir la pma à toutes
les femmes est-ce que vous voterez cette
proposition de la ce a d'abord c'est pas
parce que lui il propose que son groupe
va le proposer donc j'attends de voir si
richard ferrand est prêt à utiliser ce
qu'on appelle l'ordre du jour réservé
des parlementaires pour mettre ce sujet
à l'ordre du jour si le sujet vient au
débat moi je suis favorable à la pma
pour les couples de femmes et pour les
couples hétérosexuels
évidemment et donc après je souhaite
voir coincé libellé quelles sont les
conditions qui sont faites et j'aimerais
qu'on se pose la question dans son
ensemble là aussi sur un plan personnel
j'aimerais que on en avance aussi sur la
question du droit à connaître ses
origines pour les enfants issus de pme
cette fan équilibre je trouve utile et
qui permet de placer à la fois les
familles les enfants au coeur du débat
est-ce qu'il est opportun d'ouvrir ce
débat en ce moment est ce qu'il n'ya pas
un risque de fracture et la société avec
ces sujets là voici ce qu'ont dit à
chaque fois qu'on ouvre un débat c'était
le vrai pour l'avortement c'était vrai
pour le pacs était fait pour le mariage
pour tous et rss répandant pour la pma
je ne sais pas si ça fracturé ce que je
sais c'est que là en cette matière les
politiques sont souvent en retard sur le
plan public troisième partie des
priorités basse et oriane qui va vous
poser la question
[Musique]
question sur le parti socialiste olivier
faure à quand un parti socialiste à
l'image des bleus un parti sous des
jouant collectif mais ailleurs appris de
ses erreurs
le plus tôt sera le mieux voilà et donc
on a souvent été dans le bureau afrique
du sud
donc le mieux ce serait effectivement
qu'on apprenne alors vous aurez remarqué
que je vais sans elysées aujourd'hui
vous fait rêver oui c'est vrai mais donc
vous aurez remarqué que entre l'afrique
du sud et puis moscou
eh bien il a eu des étapes il ya eu
d'abord des quarts de finale puis des
demi finales puis une finale et donc
j'espère que les prochains scrutins qui
viennent les européennes puis municipal
puis départemental puis régional
permettront d'avoir cette lente remontée
non pas un bruit vers les champs elysées
si vous voulez en tout à l'heure des
champs il a été très critiqué au début
de compétition un oui mais sous ces noms
vous vous êtes toujours très critiqués
vous n'êtes pas déstabilisé par les gens
qui vous disent mais attendez quand
est-ce qu'il va assumer le leadership ça
vous revient aux oreilles comment vous
réagissez
ça arrive que samedi nous alors par
votre intermédiaire notamment
moi je dis simplement que ça fait trois
mois que je suis premier scrutin de ce
parti
si quelqu'un pensait qu'on pouvait
redresser un pratique a fait 6 % à
l'élection présidentielle passée de 300
députés à 30 en trois mois les écouter
chapeau je n'ai jamais pensé une seule
seconde que j'en serai capable on est
donc à le but du jeu ce n'est pas
d'ailleurs y compris de jeunes je ne
prétends pas être jupiter moi ce que je
prétend pouvoir faire c'est remettre au
travail
un collectif et si elles ne sont attirés
effectivement deux sets de ce mondial
pour nous c'est celui-là c'est d'arriver
à travailler une équipe ne pas chercher
moi je ne cherche pas à être
l'avant-centre être celui qui marque
tous les buts
d'ailleurs j'aurais remarquer qu'avant
centre dans cette équipe de france a
marqué peu de buts mais il a été un
excellent arrière donc en fait tout et
tout est possible moi ce que je veux
c'est que nos pulsions être
collectivement en mesure d'être à
nouveau une force qui est comprise et
qui est comprise abord parce qu elle est
compacte
qu'elle est capable de défendre et
d'attaquer ensemble si on arrive à face
à si on arrive à le faire derrière un
projet qui est à nouveau identifiable
identifiés alors jeu nous promet de
nouveaux succès autrement je me promets
de belles défaites encore stéphane le
foll emmanuel maurel je vous
suffisamment collectif puisque donc tous
deux étaient vos adversaires
aux congas d'aubervilliers et là ils ont
chacun leur club et emmanuel morel fait
université d'été où il invite jean luc
mélenchon que vous ne pensez tout ça
bien les clubs il y en a toujours existé
et 6 et des clubs pour réfléchir moi je
suis pour que la réflexion sur la plus
large possible et s'il arrive à étendre
notre propre stade influence sur notre
gauche dans notre droite
je prends si en revanche ces clubs ces
deux nouvelles écuries de nouveaux clans
et de nouvelles façons de nous facturer
alors là je serai sans pitié sans pitié
sans pitié exclu du parti socialiste je
ne laisserai pas ce parti qui avaient
déjà été fracturés à de multiples
reprises se fracturer à nouveau le
mandat qui m'a été confié par les
militants assez précisément celui là
c'est d'arriver à rassembler et réunir
cette famille moi ce que je veux croire
et dans les discussions que j'ai avec
les uns et les autres c'est plutôt
qu'ils ont envie maintenant de passer à
autre chose du conquet terminée tout le
monde a compris et donc maintenant il
faut avancer ensemble
mais s'il y avait la volonté
effectivement de rejouer à l'infini ce
que nous avons connu les congrès de
rennes de reims enfin pouvait citer tous
ces congrès qui ont été épouvantables et
ses 50 nouveaux noms de passer au cours
desquelles personne ne s'est sauvé en
fait ni les frondeurs ni les
légitimistes
au bout du compte n'ont réussi à faire
entendre leur voix nous avons été
ensemble
disqualifié donc soit on pense que cette
disqualification n'est pas une bonne
leçon à retenir et en continu soit on
pense au contraire que quand trop c'est
trop on arrête et bien moi je pense que
trop c'est trop
donc vous n'hésiterez pas à montrer vous
êtes aussi un homme d'autorité mais je
ne cherche pas être là et si les
circonstances il sa constance m'appelait
à l'être je le serai évidemment mais je
ne souhaite pas je ne cherche pas à
montrer que mes petits muscles multibras
et s'efface en blanc je cherche pas à
dire que je suis le nouveau camp nou 14
je dis simplement que il ya un moment où
ce que me demande le mandat que j'ai
reçu de ce congrès d'accord
effectivement de faire en sorte que
soient respectés un collectif d'ong n'a
pas fait tondre une ligne il ya des
lignes
la ligne est simple c'est le respect
d'une discipline collective c'est à dire
que on débat autant qu'il est
souhaitable mais une fois que le débat a
été tranché
il y a une parole qui est une parole
unique c'est à dire qu'il ya une voie
unique
on peut écrire des choses différemment
avec sa sensibilité avec les uns et les
autres il n'y a pas un seul champion
mais il y a par contre un seul message
et un seul but vers lequel on se dirige
pour marquer le but toujours on y
revient alors vous dites que les clubs
ont toujours existé au parti socialiste
il ya une situation qui n'a jamais
existé jusqu'à la réception par sur le
fil à les accords footballistique des
clubs c'est tous ces champions la coupe
du monde sont issus de clubs différents
mais quand ils sont en équipe de france
ils jouent ensemble et bien derrière
leur capitaine d'ailleurs capital et
vous le cap et donc c'est notamment le
seul bien sûr non mais derrière une
équipe est derrière là une volonté qui
est aussi celle de jeu j'aimerais cette
idée parce que je suis contre les
parties de supporters mais contre ces
gens qui nous accompagnent et qui sont
les militants les sympathisants ceux qui
votent pour nous eh bien tous ces gens
là ils veulent une équipe rassemblée
dans des clubs très bien ont
certainement les clubs mais une fois
qu'on a fini quand on est en formation
d' équipe de france et là on marche
ensemble d'accords alors les clubs ont
toujours existé au parti socialiste une
situation qui est assez inédite c'est
qu'il ya un ancien président socialiste
qui est toujours dans le jeu
françois hollande on va l'écouter tiens
il a fait son commentaire sur la
victoire des bleus il a dû passer un
message politique
moi je crois que et ils ont tiré toutes
les leçons après une défaite il ya
forcément une victoire au bout
voilà une victoire toujours après une
défaite et parler de lui évidemment à y
est toujours là mais oui je vois ce
qu'il vous empêche d'exister françois
hollande
non je enfin il faut rester petit ce
qu'on aime moi je sais que je suis un
inconnu presque absolu pour la plupart
des français qui me découvre parce qu'à
des émissions où je suis invitée et qui
au fur et à mesure découvre mon visage
ma voix mon style ma façon de penser
mais je ne suis pas dérangé c'est
simplement évident qu'un ancien
président de la république par la force
par l'impact qu'il que sa parole peut
avoir quand il prononce une phrase dans
les bains publics évidemment il domine
très largement ce que je peux dire mais
je n'en prend pas ombrage parce que je
sais d'où je viens
mais je sais aussi où je vais mais vous
disiez tout à l'heure que vous vouliez
procédé match après match étape après
étape pour filer la métaphore il ya une
échéance qui vient tout de suite qui est
celle des européennes
et il se pourrait que vous continuiez à
descendre la pente puisque certains vous
sondage vous annonce à 4%
est ce que ces européennes elles peuvent
pas avoir quand même un rôle de couperet
et marquer définitivement l'effacement à
mort de plm il y aura un minorisation du
ps au sein de la gauche quand il ya
toujours un risque
il n'y a pas de pratiquer soit
immortelle en a d'autres qui ont tombé
avant nous et donc je passerai un sarong
en vous disant que je sais d'ores et
déjà que nous serons les premiers
partout tout le temps dans cinq ans je
n'en sais strictement rien j'en ai c'est
cette volonté là avec envoyé deux
sondages 4% au national rien à brûler
frémir
il a d'autres à 8 y en a d'autres je
frémis non je reste calme parce que le
débat n'a pas commencé et donc
aujourd'hui on mesure l'influencent des
logos respectifs et on s'aperçoit que le
logo ps effectivement peut être 4 il
peut être à 8
on est dans la marge d'erreur est donc
tout ça me met faits me laisse de marbre
d'accord mais ce que je sais c'est pour
répondre à stéphane yelle rouge
ce que je sais c'est que à l'évidence il
n'y a pas de garantie non plus moi je ne
sais pas si demain nous serons encore
présent nous pouvons très bien
disparaître c'est vrai ça suppose de
notre part donc y compris parfois de
penser contre nous mêmes se dire être
capable de se dire que si nous avons
échoué il ya un an ce n'est pas le fait
du hasard et c'est ce que je reproche
aujourd'hui à deux champions du déni que
sont benoît hamon et françois hollande
c'est d'être l'un et l'autre dans une
forme de réassurance personnel comme si
rien ne s'était passé mais cette défaite
elle est d'abord lié au fait qu'on a eu
benoît hamon et françois hollande qui
ont l'un comme l'autre conduit la gauche
à être à 6 % au bout du compte et ce
sont les chantiers dont rezaï
aujourd'hui et donc nous avons
aujourd'hui
nécessité de nous remettre forcément en
question bien sûr parce que si nous nous
remettons pas en question mais que se
passera-t-il
est ce que vous croyez que les français
vont nous faire confiance à nouveau sur
l'année - est-ce qu'ils vont se dire
finalement on a mal on a mal agi envers
eux ce sera 12 la prochaine fois mais
non ils vont nous dire à nous dire non
ils vont nous dire c'est pas possible
alors pour peut-être marquer des points
grimper dans les sondages aux
européennes il ya la question de la tête
de liste de la tête de liste on cite le
nom de christiane taubira est ce que ce
serait une bonne tête de liste pour voir
ce que vous discutez avec elle de ça ce
serait une bonne tête de liste comme
d'autres est à ce stade
j'échange avec nombre de ceux qui
pourraient potentiellement être tête de
liste à l'européenne mais si tu aimais
bien non les autres non lésés non je
vais pas tous les citer beaucoup dans le
parti il ya beaucoup de talent dans ce
parti encore heureusement mais à ce
stade moi je préfère que nous
commencions là aussi par nous poser des
questions de fond donc il faut commencer
par se dire ce que nous avons à nous
dire c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on porte
et quand nous serons au clair sur ce que
nous portons chercher une incarnation
qui correspond à ce que nous portons
parce que ce débat là aussi il faut être
capable de se dire que depuis 2005 on
s'est posé peu de questions alors en
tous les cas fiez vous dites que vous
n'êtes pas très connu a reconnu par
l'opinion mais apparemment le
positionnement adopté par le parti
socialiste a été bien perçue par
l'opinion c'est le thème de notre
deuxième question du sondage opinionway
le ps est-il selon vous opposer à la
politique d' emmanuel macron 77%
favorable il ya 21 % qu'il le pense si
vous avez écouté ce soir et seront
basculés dans le vôtre car que
effectivement j'aurais été suffisamment
clair mais je ne me satisfais pas c'est
pas seulement l'opposition s'est pas
seulement de dire que manuel macron ça
ne va pas je suis suffisamment lucide
aussi pour dire que nous non plus ne
veulent pas donc il ya encore du travail
et que ce serait trop simple de parier
simplement sur l'échec des autres moi je
ne veux pas être simplement celui bien
sûr je le fais je dis manuel macron sera
pas dans la bonne direction mais à nous
d'être inventif créatif et ne pas nous
reposer sur des lauriers que nous
n'avons pas en dernière minute juste
pour reprendre sur 100 au pire à une des
conditions qu'elle avait mise pour
éventuellement participer à cette
campagne c'était l'union de la gauche
là on voit que a priori les verts ont
trouvé leur tête de liste qui sera
yannick jadot probablement est-ce que
vous croyez le moins du monde à cette
union de la gauche ou est-ce que voilà
vous allez devoir vous affrontez les
verts les communistes et les autres
j'adore ce qu'ils désignent les
générations etc
moi je j'ai dit à plusieurs semaines que
la porte était ouverte à toutes les
discussions
maintenant je ne vais pas courir après
les uns et les autres ce que je sais
c'est que ensemble il ya plus de chances
d'être vécue comme une alternative à ce
que sera la liste d'union dans marche
avec les libéraux et avec lui dit et
donc qu'on a plutôt intérêt à chercher
ce qui peut unir plutôt que ce qui
fragmentent maintenant ces débats
d'appareils mon lacet depuis fort
longtemps et donc moi je ne suis plus
prêt à passer ma vie avec les uns et les
autres à se demander et une bonne qu
avec le donne quoi et c'est donc ce sera
devant les électeurs directement et moi
je le ferai donc il y aurait ce genre de
sa liste qu'il ya qu il y a une offre
qui corresponde à ce que je veux porter
qui soit peut-être plus large même que
ce que nous offrons habituellement à
voir mais voilà ce serait sans les
appareils on le fera directement les
français bonnes vacances pour reprendre
des forces pour la rentrée mais réservés
comme nous tous c'est la fin de cette
émission merci madame fin de l'épreuve
de vérité également puisqu'on nous
retrouverons une nouvelle émission à la
rentrée en partenariat avec la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale une
émission que j'aurai l'honneur de
présenter bonnes vacances
[Musique]